le secteur de la défense et de
l'aérospatiale civil ou militaire est
très fortement implanté dans les
yvelines avec des grands groupes leaders
européens voire mondiaux comme thales
safran ou airbus défense airbus defense
and space acteur majeur aux multiples
activités civiles et militaires est
implanté depuis longtemps aux mureaux
avec sa filiale qui fabrique la fusée
ariane
mais aussi à elancourt où sont employées
près de 2000 personnes principalement
des ingénieurs dans des activités
digitales chargé de la cybersécurité il
développe également des outils de
télécommunications terrestres
il fabrique des équipements spatiaux
mais aussi la conception et la
fabrication de drones des drones
aujourd'hui indispensable aux missions
de nos armées vous avez derrière moi
tous les produits drones qui sont conçus
à elancourt par nos équipes d'ingénieurs
qui pilotent notre activité drone depuis
elancourt vous avez derrière moi le le
drone harfang qui est celui qui équipe
les armées françaises actuellement et
les petits drones qui sont utilisés par
l'armée de terre donc c'est une activité
qui est tout à fait d'actualité et pour
laquelle on essaie de développer un
service civil pour faire voler les
drones à des fins gouvernementales ou
d'organismes comme loana fou avions
civils ou militaires hélicoptère lanceur
spatial
airbus va bien et l'implantation dans
les yvelines et pérenne la croissance de
ce secteur profite à l'économie locale
la fabrication de tous ses avions ses
satellites fait appel à une multitude de
sous-traitants dans le département des
petites sociétés spécialisées
indispensable acte i dig est l'une
d'entre elles cette pme de 25 personnes
est installée à elancourt et fabrique
des pièces pour les plus grands
fournisseurs
elle est présente au salon tant pour son
image que pour maintenir des contacts
avec ses partenaires industriels
elle est installée au pavillon de la
région ile de france qui compte près de
200 sociétés à sa tête un ancien de
dassault l'entreprise fabrique des
machines de précision qui vont servir à
calibrer des pièces nécessaires pour
guider des avions civils ou militaires
comme le rafale
quand raffole ne pourrait pas assurer sa
navigation
sans notre société parce que bien
entendu nos clients ce sont les grands
de la navigation
c'est des sociétés comme sagem comme
comme thales le fait d'être dans
elancourt dans les yvelines je dirais
dans le grand paris en général c'est que
quand on regarde bien toutes les grandes
entreprises dans leurs bureaux d'études
dans l'eure ont leur finalement dans
leurs centres de décisions localement
également vous n'êtes pas loin des
grands aéroports qui permet de se
déplacer
c'est donc tout un département avec de
nombreuses entreprises petites ou
grandes qui a été mis en valeur lors de
ce 52e salon international de
l'aéronautique du bourget le bilan de
cette édition 2010 est est très positif
pour l'ensemble du secteur plus de 150
milliards de dollars de commandes ont
été signés lors de ce salon